is this entertaining every time you launch into
that song i think it's gonna be a little butterfly
no no no john it's bones by image and dragon oh
dang the best band guys we're gonna watch the
boys season three episode thresh today last
thing we are recording here before moving
from this nightmare if you guys can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated doesn't take too
much work on your end full-length watch logs where
you sync up with the type code are available for
the super sexiest rejects in the world reaction
highlights and watch alongs included for exclusive
shows as well subscribe and click the notification
bell get notified when our reaction for the next
episode of the boys is up you'll probably hear
some noise because uh the missus is moving stuff
around right now since we gotta pack up everything
we are recording into right now tonight as well
the boys at prepper they shop and set it down
these highlights you guys wrong but the real
lastly thank you to storyblocks for partnering
up with us this month as we have been hiring
some more editors and some new on-screen talent to
be here more regularly working with these brands
is helping to keep us producing
more of these videos and to be
trying out some new things as well so
sincerely thank you let's get to this
and don't tense up when you hit the high it
notes it's pain as weakness leaving the body
that's right we do whatever it takes to win so
you go out there and just keep smiling okay baby
that's it starlight block that
[__] up keep shooting that body
baby baby how was i supposed to know
that something wasn't right yeah okay
wowie very impressive there is star late
bernie should hire her for her residency
keep me me impotent and obedient
like i'm a [__] puppet
you know what it worked hey ashley what's
crisis management saying about that i don't know
poor ashley i am done being
persecuted for my strength
samurai mr done being persecuted for my strength
several videos are persecuted for my strength
persecuted i do this with our videos this
is the plight of white dudes everywhere
wow what do you mean i'm
up 21 points with your base
21 points they loved your speech a massive
44 uptake with white males in the rust belt
of course you're saying you're confident
and unapologetic and that you know you're not
afraid to keep [__] going ashley don't stop
that's got nothing to do with you just keep going
oh jeez they want me to be myself and now um
oh no together you have a q rating
of 98 no one's ever been that high
not soldier boy not anyone look how everyone
brings up soldier boy so much more now you know
they've just started bringing him up all
the time that's wrapped like twice lassies
like a bit of power right i
got this feeling in my bunk
look i know what you're going to say no no
and i just wait i'm just chuffed to have all
the boys back under the same roof right really
i mean there he was right in his fancy pants
old time he weren't nothing but
a soup's bootleg eh yeah that
my son is a lifetime achievement
at the [__] of the year awards
truly back uh can you please break my arm
vicky you'll smell it if i fake being sick
so it's got to be real and it's
gotta last for days hardcore huey
have a seat please we've been in three minutes
and it's already the bold and the bad [__]
oh my god one
two
you do know that i have a boyfriend
right love triangles they generate a 47
surge in trending topics on social platforms
let me talk to him first amazing uh what do you
think of our second choice moonshadow she's
body positive but not too body positive ugh
she's the most qualified well we're gonna have
to run all of this past homelander of course
actually according to my contract with mr
edgar i get the final say over the two slots
so why don't you run that password
oh no ashley don't turn on her
did you bring the password
why do you have to leave i went back to work for
little nina i was moving wait for her and these
[__] [__] boosted him can you find them
they wear masks i don't know who they were
and i was high oh they want to pick you as one
of the winners tonight and you need to say no
why there's something wrong with homelanders
something broken he's threatened to murder
me more than once he's murdered oh no and you're
just gonna be putting yourself and your family in
danger please you need to promise me that you
will leave and you'll never look back please
i hope you don't snitch on her i'm afraid he might
i've never been to nicaragua really because
a little birdie told me you were payback's
case officer down there whatever it is william
thinks he may have heard he's mistaken is he
nicaragua's ancient history not to mention i could
be killed just for telling you and all your agents
will get killed if you don't would i pick them
reagan's pet project off the books some of the
cash came from selling arms to iran oliver north's
epic fuck-up but the rest um it was cocaine i was
in charge of trafficking the coke into the u.s
and then using the profits to buy more weapons wow
[__] payback each more ridiculous than the next
what do you say gunpowder give them the fourth
of july let's light them up please put that down
you know with a figure like
yours you are wasted down here
my humblest apologies i'm sure this
is disoriented that's ted egger
officer grace mallory isn't it stanford yeah jeez
think of it as a trial run a trial run from what
superheroes in the military of course for the
first time in over 30 years just imagine how dumb
they belong and that's incredible tell that's
a soldier boy he's a living breathing american
hero i'm not allowing this i'm sure director
casey will address any concerns you may have
fetch water for our tents thank you so much
he has a pretty good young chunk harlem yeah he's
got the the rhythm and the sort of erudite cadence
can you please stop eating those
in front of me i'm allergic
so listen oh my god black noir's voice silent
ninja score extremely high with boys 17 years old
the mask lends a certain mystique [__] mystique
you know if you were a little nicer maybe you'd
find a man stood out here playing captain lesbo
v24 reactions going through a
little withdrawal there buddy
ashley tells me that you chose
silver king k kinkade i have notes
i have notes i choose the new members but i am
pitching the craziest twist well i've made my
decision oh come on you haven't even heard
it yet seriously you're gonna love it ready
return of the deal no oh you
[__] before you say anything
doesn't christ tell us to turn the other cheek
i need a word these two chat shall we absolutely
not do you really think i'm gonna let a muslim in
the seven jesus do i need to remind you
of the flight 37 video release it let's
light this candle huh i mean sure i'll lose
everything but then i'll have nothing to lose
go ahead partner do it
come on stan must have thought of
something to fail safe for the homelander
oh yeah yeah like that oh
no
butcher are you okay hear me oh good just
gives a minute yeah do you need any help oh
no don't come in no uh we have to be as mean and
[__] up as they are no you sound like butcher
i know but annie he's right he's been right all
along i'm just so tired of losing this is noble
i didn't want to say nothing but i was trying
to show the community i'm down for the carlos
says when you've been down with any cause
i was terrified luhak came to her rescue the
suspect became aggressive brother lived a few
houses up the street he was just walking home
from work blue hawk curb stomped him so hard to
crack the pavement oh my goodness maybe i can
throw his family some cash or something they
don't need a handout they need you to speak up
you're in the [__] seven yeah but i mean oh dude
nina wants to see you he's guinea how's your wife
she still enjoys getting herself tossed by
a french man while her husband does nothing
come on frenchie you take on soups
has it been less than 24 hours either
that or it doesn't work that way
suado went for another joy flight giving
away our position even better the sandinistas
brought russian special forces with them
though that didn't matter much to the soups
god damn it bunch of idiots
oh man jesus
got cannibal holocausted
god this team is so frustrated
up the gore this season man
oh ah black noir
can't talk no more oh dude
oh god thank you soldier boy
do the russians haven't maybe wait up where
where are you going see what will i see you again
you won't it's safe for you oh butcher
you said you'd always walked out for me
you promised ryan let go i won't let you
well maybe i don't want to look at you
after what you've done on my bicker
did you ever think about that oh
no oh no hit you
that's bad you might have just made things a whole
lot worse sorry if you've gained he goes a little
rough still a bit bitter you ate his wife's
anus friend she likes to rim where is shelley
because nobody stole hair in front of her she
stole it from me what was your safe word again
when i used the dog collar and
the strap on what was it vincent
just think about my offer go
on scamper away little doggy
damn i don't know if i've ever seen this actress
before oh thanks homelander this
literally means everything to me
of course oh you cruel bastard you're back in the
big leagues buddy nothing but the best for you
he only gave him a plate
christ you know who i've been reading
up on lately dr martin luther king well
my relationship with king is deepened of light
of course it has so villainized persecuted spoke
my god i mean they [__] love me
there's always been so so many things i
want to do and now i can do them all finally
oh no ugh what's for you big guy me
specialty it is a south korean delicacy
you knew it oh damn it oh my god
it's tim he's my friend i uh i can't eat
them i'm not going to eat them oh yes yes
hey deep what eat [__] timothy
oh
oh buddy no
i'm so sorry
he's gonna puke wasn't that delicious
god damn that was so mean set
up a mean with you me and then
nina not no this is a very it's a very bad
idea no frenchie it's a very [__] good idea
we miss you and what are we doing this for good
dog because my son we're going to russia there
we go that lines up i told him i was thrilled to
join the team no alex alex that's that's a mistake
i was in rehab but you didn't leave do
you really think i'm gonna bail on you now
i'm an [__] but i'm not that much of an [__]
kiss him yeah it's gonna happen at some point
no the others don't get it but i do
if there's anything that i've learned
thank you
final new member of the seven
is the seventh sees the deep
ugh well frankly i'm moved and
inspired that starlight here has
chosen to forgive you i accept your apology deep
you deserve a second chance thank you starlight
thank you sterling you keep your distance
pal because uh well she's my girl now
i'm sorry i i can't keep it
a secret anymore no no no no
no no hashtag homelight cut
huh incredible god [__] play
yeah let's uh let's go again okay one more
do it again great starlight and i are in love
all the pain fascinating booking
oh that's so cruel that's just the number one
thing hopelander knows how to do is
just find the cruelest possible thing
oh and surprise i'd surprise you with this how
does that come at all oh i have nipple chills
but not the good cops dreadful nipple juice
the most sinister nipple gels nipple shivers
yeah that don't mess me up that poor woman
that poor real life woman yes
justice for any january yeah
oh that's that's sick so sick disgusting
but hey everything's good with the deep so
yeah it's good all right let's talk about it
well hey to check out this word
from our sponsor today storybooks
best sponsor love them yep let's
slide in the mood a tad bit for just
yeah thank you for sponsoring this video thank
you to storyblocks for sponsoring this video being
the cinematic artisans we obviously are we are
always in search of ways to make our videos look
better faster and most of all for cheap cheap is
good and if you're a content creator or filmmaker
or anything in between you're probably in a
similar position it's tough to get your content
looking as good as it can be without breaking the
bank or burning yourself out in the process which
is why i heavily encourage you guys to check
out what storyblocks has to offer cheap is good
do you feel like this is their way of telling
us that the videos could be looking better yes
whether it's the credibility of an exotic
establishing shot the soothing comfort of
the perfect music bed or just the satisfaction of
increasing your graphical capability storybox has
an incredibly inclusive and diverse library of
faces places sounds titles transitions filters
and effects and more over a million assets royalty
free and available for personal and commercial use
with your membership sounds so affordable this is
quite affordable they have multiple subscription
levels to suit your exact needs whether you're
an independent indie solo creator or a whole team
so if you want to learn more head on down
to our link in the description box and get
started that's at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video anyway
yeah that won't put me in a
mood i can uh why how what mood
i feel affected by it the other ones have
left me more like um jazzed and uh this one
is uh it's really interesting when you when you
do the comparison of the release of season two and
season three with the three episodes yeah where
season two was like building building crazy yeah
when it gets there it's worth it and then this was
like crazy crazy and this is starts off crazy and
and then oh wow this is just really dark
and uncomfortable it starts crazy and that
de-escalates into what's true the rim underneath
badassness i like it i like it i i wouldn't have
it any other way to be honest it is so unsettling
and and uh it it it it's unnerving in a way that
is so it's uncomfortable yes uncomfortable is like
the most simple word i could find but it's so true
because everything they're doing with the with
these characters is because this was more like
this more somber moments they had more dramatic
moments while even even when you're seeing payback
in uh where were they corrupt yeah when you're
seeing payback they're in the reagan time and
there i thought it might be like oh wacky you
know we're seeing this some characters feel like
spoof of the avengers you know so obviously with
soldier boy and being like the captain america
suado kind of sort of reminded you of that man had
a feeling it would be a little bit more of that
that sues the suicide squad that's kind
of like a superhero thing to do now is
introduce a team and kill off a bunch of them
yeah you know all kind of dopey characters and
then yeah you watch them die terribly yeah but
even like a recent movie and i won't say just
in case people haven't seen it but even in
a recent movie in a recent stuff happening
how many recent comic movies are there you
probably you know what i'm talking about
early june so just think back uh yeah so
even that it's kind of a superhero thing
to do although it's not like surprising here just
because of the fact that payback isn't a prevalent
team uh at the moment but but seeing the the the
harrowing stuff that mallory went through that it
wasn't that she's just some traitor that she was
taking advantage of and used in this situation
and experienced so much suffering and loss from
it and she has her core memory for why she goes
after supes and why she hates bot so much and uh
and then everything with even a train you know
by possibly going down the path of actually caring
about the community actually caring about black
people in a way and caring about their suffrage
instead of just oh i could capitalize off of
the pain of black culture and use it as a way
to lift myself up and be back in the seven as
like top dog but really no that's not the case
and now here he's being witnessed that you see
him being affected by a real uh element of real
world crime that occurs and of course uh you know
it is a fascinating bookend with starlight
to show her back with her mom of what stage
mom being used and how she the clenching of the
fist is a yeah act of us like directing the pain
or kind of harm it's not really harming yourself
but it can be if you go too hard you could like
if you have long nails you can harm yourself
but it is like um directing the pain and now
to be back here where she's just becoming so
closed off again where she thought this would be
her season as well where everything would be good
and now it's worse than before you know it's back
to being taken advantage of so yeah this was even
with the deep i felt bad for him i gotta admit
like deep's not a character i often feel bad for
you someone was going to just pity but killing uh
killing timothy that was messed up that was really
messed up i'm an animal lover so that really
really bothered me i don't care about animals so i
thought that scene was hilarious hilarious eating
get [__] yeah what's the big deal it's just
food you hear a coward what's the difference
fish come on man climb that corporate ladder no
i absolutely agree this has been a fascinating
turn because yeah we've sat here and said you know
each of these feels like its own kind of centered
episode and it doesn't need like you know
the other episodes around it to feel complete
or like a complete start although this first
chunk as of this episode does kind of solidify
something over the three even though they
do feel more independent than season two's
kickoff episodes yeah by this point you get the
full setting of the place that homelander is under
like just ex every time there's just exponentially
fewer controls and safeguards on him and and
that's something that each you know each season
they're pretty good at developing these stakes
where i'm like this could be like devastating
to the entire world and how are they going to
figure this out and also top this or you know come
up with something just as engaging next season
and i appreciate that they don't pull
punches that way so yeah with homelander
especially as of this third episode you're sitting
here going like man he he really can't do like
whatever he wants and unless they find this
weapon but i have to imagine it's not going
to ultimately come down to the weapon in the way
that we expect like it really does feel hopeless
as of this moment this episode specifically
and two you feel just the depth of depravity
that propping all this stuff up requires and i
feel like this episode being the one where huey
and it's been interesting to watch his turn as
well basically sort of surrendering to the idea
of look yeah i tried to do it legit and even the
legit way is filled with secrets and lies and and
horrific circumstances so starlight can you please
just soldier through this and like it's really
heartbreaking to watch that at the end because you
know that there are so many overlapping contexts
and you've got super sonic and you're like well
maybe he will at least be an ally to her during
this situation i could also really understand
though how he could get suckered into this whole
you know dog and pony show that is the seven and
that is vaught and that yeah just perpetuates
this ever twisting just you know and spiral
into the depths of awful human behavior and so
yeah it's like everything starlight does from
here on out seems like it's just going to be
trauma and uh yeah to like center back in on that
like the way that he has invaded and that he the
homelander like overtly uh just like sadistically
exerts his control and authority over people is
like is really unnerving especially when you think
that yeah this is a really heightened caricature
of various modes of pop culture and various
aspects of society but at the same time
especially in recent years of what we've
learned is possible out there in the corporate
and uh socio-economic political worlds you
know it also feels like it's echoing something
true and and disgusting and i mean you know it's
we're watching this not not that there are super
direct parallels but it's like it's funny to watch
this while there's like a major uh you know abuse
and defamation trial happening in popular culture
because then you have examples of how those
things happen how they happen in entertainment
scenarios and how they happen with these giant
marketing apparatuses surrounding them to sculpt
the truth like yeah it's nice because you've got
all the cool superhero you know uh edgy [__]
but then you can think about stuff like that
and that's kind of the impression this episode
left on me is that you know yeah it's cruel stuff
i think this one this episode was showing that
everyone's just giving in to their darkness this
time around like everyone is succumbing to the
darkest parts of themselves and the most desperate
yes and and and in many ways yeah it's for some
people the most desperate and other ones like
like homelander there's nothing desperate
about it to him with him he's just he i i
i think it's a commentary on trumpism and in many
ways uh like there's other types of personalities
but again knowing who this show is developed by
the producers involved and how spoken they are
a lot of the commentary of of this guy of you
know i want to be loved and if i can't be loved
i will gladly be feared and i will ruin your life
is just so diabolical which is a big theme with
some of these characters diabolical usually being
like oh so fun and messed up this is this is uh
psychologically messed up butcher succumbing
to his own darkness when he was on a path of
filling himself with more light you know
he reached a breaking point but then he
rejects ryan and hurts him and you could
tell how tortured he is by such a decision
but he gave into his darkness he was giving
into his darkness starlight's giving it to
her darkness everyone is giving it to their
darkness frenchy um coming to terms with
he's not a leader and he is often used as you
know as the woman put it like a dog you know who
just always needs someone to take orders from and
work for and even then you see that moment where
when he's talking to a butcher and he says no and
he's can we see how how with the scene beforehand
how he wants nothing to do with this woman and it
hates this whole possibility of going back to her
and stuff and it took took him some balls to stand
up to her and then butcher pushes just a tiny bit
and you can see butcher's putting his foot down
for it and he gives in everyone's just giving in
it's it's this was a really dark episode to me
this was a very very dark episode the deep even
like eating his own friend yeah the whole thing
with his wife well his wife yeah celebrity wife
goddamn opportunist wife
and good i i like the casting too for young
malory and young uh uh stan edgar too i thought
stan edgar felt like an impression yeah like a
like a solid impression but also too like i'm not
a lot i'm more focused on like this is not a bad
impression yeah but uh especially the one who
played grace mallory i thought she did a terrific
job and did a lot to humanize her experience
poor ryan i really liked what they were doing
i was really happy about that was an unexpected
dynamic that the trailers didn't even lead on is
something that this show would be doing with them
getting along like that's heartbreaking i've never
quite been heartbroken with this show yeah as much
as i love it there's some things here that like
really hurt well because with ryan i think that's
great because you have such a thin line like you
could see how just a couple of the right traumatic
moments could you know warp this kid not to the
same degree as a homelander but in a way that is
sort of unmitigated and volatile yeah and could
get to there because you obviously of who his dad
is uh and so yeah i feel like it's heartbreaking
and there's just bigger stakes because it's like
if anybody needs to be looked out for and and you
know nurtured the right way it's it's probably
this kids well they do a lot of in this show of
viewing the world through media yep yeah you know
they often even at the beginning of this episode
there's those sequences where people are watching
the world unfold through television you know
controlling the media media propaganda a lot of
the time and you think about a character like ryan
who is who did accidentally murder his own mom
and who is the dad is celebrated as
this glorious hero yeah super loved
he knows the truth that he is villainous and vile
and then you get rejected by surrogate father
and surrogate father leaves you saying what you
did to your mom it's like you to me that's scary
like wow i butchered you know if you wanted
to leave him fine i mean not fine but
don't push the kid down a path that could
eventually snowball him same as telling
your dog to leave yeah in some old movie yeah
that's that to me was very that was very um
i was like that was not a smart choice yeah
it was that was like that could lead to some
terrible consequences yeah when they're standing
by the window and he's like i feel so bad i'm
like maybe you could have chosen a different way
to do the same thing you just did without and i
know that part of that is a snap in the moment
but it's also like i i need to separate myself
from you because of all this danger you know it is
interesting what they're unpacking and i wish that
i kind of wish the trailers didn't show us
the jets and necklaces yeah he's being stored
somewhere for resurrection in modern day time yeah
it would be nice to just have it be a surprise
like oh he's playing him in the flashbacks cool
cool good to know it's nice to have him here but
i won't get too you know uh attached or or you
know intent on yeah a certain version of this
yeah i i think this i think what this is
showing is like we always know that there's the
the line that homeowner could cross to being uh
the person who commits mass genocide we we know
that he could he's capable of that like the
way he flips that conversation with starlight
like the last season ended with the leverage
of you will not be loved you know they had the
crowd noise of him thinking a bunch of people are
chanting homeland or that's the thing he lives for
he wants to be loved and you know he goes yeah
but if i you he if he has nothing to lose then
screw it it's just just world domination
global domination global destruction
and i keep thinking like there's got to be
something that they developed as a fail safe
to take him out there has to be something along
the way that they developed where worst case
if we a [__] because like stan anger shows no
fear towards him yeah and sometimes i go are you
sure you want to be that way around him because
yeah what do you got man what what true leverage
especially now what do you have and i almost
wonder if this season might set up for a stan
egg or death well i think he likes to watch people
suffer in all kinds of ways it doesn't matter what
it is but that's what he gets off on that more
than anything else is watching people suffer
uh like inviting the deep back in as a way to make
starlight suffer but then to also torture the deep
is is so such a safest feeling he's such a
sick guy and uh he's always got to reinforce
his control by by breaking the people around
him and you know in that speech he's giving
him like i could do whatever i want and
people will love me like that's the key
and i don't know it's like he forgot
some things he did last season then
or he's just not going to care about a certain
demographic yeah he's not going to care about
them you know like oh your points dropped
these urban communities but this community
really loves you so i'm just going to lean into
that where and because in last season there were
the people were protesting against like even this
season starts off because of things he did yeah
yeah you know um but there is a group
out there that really depending on how he
how he handles his composure and confidence
around situations that that's the thing is like
if if you are someone who can proceed with like no
[__] given you're just gonna be a really strong
and you're just gonna be confident in what you're
doing i'm not wrong i'm not gonna apologize for
[__] yeah you will attract an audience and who
doesn't people love people who tell it like it is
but when you try to be apologetic or try to spin
into something else people you know get mad at
the fact that they feel there's they're looking
at a lie they're looking at a mask yeah you know
weakness yeah where it's like if you just show
who you are underneath you will find the people
because at the end of the day there's always this
level of some type of whether it's good or bad
if you're there's something about honesty that's
appealing yeah um well yeah i'd follow homelander
that's good yeah it's the depths of this
world into the depths of depravity and beyond
i do it no matter what you have to eat no
well you know even with huey though like
telling her telling starlight you know at least
as honest with her as opposed to bullshitting
her about stuff but even telling her like yeah
you gotta suffer and i'm putting your life on on
edge entirely yeah you're at risk at every moment
now because we have a cause we gotta fulfill oh
you're gonna lose her man i think one way or the
other they can't they can't that's the rule of
romantic couples in these kinds of shows can't
stay together forever what's super sonic's power
you know they they talked about it can he get
can he get does he have like supersonic speed
abilities agility or is it like some kind of
wave projection i know they did that american
hero you know in the show that they're doing
here they did some obstacle course bit but
it was very brief and the rest of the time he's
just behind the scenes on the show we're dancing
yeah yeah we'll see it we'll see i mean we'll
i imagine now that he's part of the seven we'll
see him do some stuff yeah out in the field i
wonder how that character's gonna get a twist too
because they've developed him thus far as a pretty
upstanding person and they talk in this episode
about like you know i was an addict and i had all
this recovery to do and it seems like he's really
done it but also i know that you know you got a
character like homelander if he gets even a whiff
of that history he's gonna you know use that
to his advantage so i'm very worried for that
character because he seems so wholesome right now
especially with everything they've had like all
the opportunities he's had to be skeevy about the
starlight and huey business and all that stuff but
yeah this was this is maddening in a lot of
ways this episode maddening and soul crushing
all right well we're done
thanks for being here we'll
see you guys soon